The Joe Rogan experience. I was in college. I was a basketball player. Right.
And my coach tells, tells me, hate mark. There's,
there's some European Scouts that are, that are interested in you, you know,
maybe after, you know, next year, you know,
they may want to give you a tryout European pro basketball. Right.
But they all say they wanna get you, you know,
they'd like for you to be a little bigger cause of the style they played back
then. Okay. So I start lifting weights, trying, you know,
I'm six foot 8, 2 30, 2 40, which is in,
in the eighties is huge for a basketball player, but still,
so I started training European league. Were they just more physical? Yeah. Yeah.
You know, it was like, uh, Rick Mahorn and, and bill lamb beer, you know,
on the gas, they were just monsters. And um,
so I start training and I'm trying to, you know, put on size and strength.
And I met this guy in the gym who was like, every day I'd come in.
He goes, Hey, he goes, man, I'm gonna, I'm gonna go. And I'm going,
I'm gonna get into this wrestling. Why don't you do wrestling with man?
I was a big wrestling fan as a kid, but as I got into, you know,
basketball and football and everything else, I kind of, you know,
kind of drifted away you. And I was just like, uh, man,
I think I'm gonna go try to play some pro ball in Europe. And, and he goes, ah,
man, you should really try and do this with me, you know?
So I kind of start getting in touch with the product again, you know,
I kind of start watching again and you know, no clue, uh,
I thinking, you know, you know, kind fall back into it again, right? Like, oh,
that's kind of cool. That's different. And
I think one of the things that's helped me through my career is, is being a, a,
a realist as, and what my talents are and what my talents are. And, you know,
I was like, you know, I kinda started having these conversations with myself.
Like, even if you do make a team, you know, I mean,
how long do you really have? Right. And,
and being 21 and sitting on the end of the bench and Lithuania just really
didn't, wasn't that appealing. Yeah. Of a, you know, I'm, you know,
I'm trying to weigh it up against what I'm seeing on TV. Right. And I'm like,
you know, I'm like, because you got Theon Erics and you got Hogan. I'm like,
well, these guys are huge household names, you know?
So I'm thinking maybe I'll give it a try.
So we find this guy by the name of buzz Sawyer to train us.
Now I gotta come up with two grand and I ain't got a pot or a window to throw it
out of. Right. So I, uh, I get my brother,
my oldest brother to co-sign loan, Hawk, everything I own. And, uh,
come up with two grand to pay bus Sawyer, to train, train me to Russell
show up to his house. Uh, first morning of training. Right.
And buzz was a, he was a, he was a good amateur,
really good amateur and, uh, show up at his house, knocking on the door,
knocking on there's about 10 of us standing out in the front yard,
knocking on the door, finally, door swings, open, what the you want? Right.
He's saying there butt naked. <laugh> woke him up out of a day.
He's just standing there naked. And everybody's like, uh, we're here to train.
And he goes, oh. Is that today? <laugh> yeah. Yeah.
And, uh, so he, he gets a, another guy that was staying there with him.
His name was Perry Jackson, who I'm friends with to this day. Uh, he says,
go out there and warm him up. Right.
So he goes out there and we run and do all just, I mean,
everything they can do to blow us up and run us off. Right. Totally.
Gased out two hours. Just nothing but cardio. Right.
Finally buzz comes out, all right. Everybody line up, you know,
all right, everybody get down amateur position. Right. So, you know,
everybody gets down, he just stretches the outta everybody. Right.
Like cross phase, you know, chicken w and just,
just hooking everybody and rolling him around in, in his front yard. Right.
It just, that was it. Right. Then he goes in the house. So y'all come back,
you know, a couple other days. So this goes on for weeks. And like,
every time I show up, there's like one less guy that shows up.
They just like until I was the last one there. So I'm the last one there.
I knock on the door, knock on the door.
He never answers. Right. So I start peering in the windows,
all the furniture's gone, everything's gone, he's gone.
He's gone to a different territory to work. He just left. Right. Never,
never learned any pro wrestling.
But he just teaching you wrestling wrestl.
He was just teaching me. Yeah. Obviously he, we signed up for pro you know,
to get, to teach us how to pro wrestle,
but he just came out there and his whole goal,
and this is the way it was back then is they always tried to take your money.
And then they tried to run you off, you know? Oh,
most of the guys that in that era were all shooters. You know, they were all,
you know, they all good amateurs. Right. And that was what they would do.
They would take your money. Then they'd hurt you, twist you it'd hurt, you know,
try and get you to quit. And they got your money and they, you know,
they didn't have.
To worry about it.
There's some wrestling trainers that were famous for like crazy physical
training standards before they ever taught you anything like Carl Gotch.
Oh yeah, sure. You know, Carl gotchas, Carl gotchu is, uh, not just a,
a wrestler,
but one of the he's like one of the legends of catch wrestling and catch
wrestling is like, uh,
so it's a lot like submission wrestling that you see in the U in the UFC or in
jujitsu, but it's, uh, very like wrestling oriented. So instead of like,
whereas jujitsu maybe would be,
I don't wanna say it's less technical, but it's more violent. Like,
it's a lot of snapping people down and cross facing and guillo teens and
10 finger guillo teens. And there's still a lot of like, um,
SA Rabo was like one of the legends of MMA learned. Yeah. From, uh,
another catch wrestler in Japan.
And a lot of guys who like Josh Barnett is another one. Who's a big, uh,
catch wrestling enthusiast. He, his style is, and he, you know,
he submitted a lot of like really elite guys,
but Carl go was famous for making you, you had to,
you had to be able to do crazy. Like,
I think you had to do a thousand body weight squats. You had to be able to do,
like, you had to do all these things before you even teach you yeah.
Anything like you had to be tip top McGoo before you would ever get into those
ropes.
Yeah, absolutely. And that was the whole goal was to run you off, you know,
weed out the week, read out the we. Yeah. Yeah.
And then if you went through all of that and you were still there. Okay. Well,
this kid, you know, let's see what he, you know,
let's see if we can teach him how to do this,
but there was that big weed out process. And that was you.
I think Buzz's whole deal. His whole deal was a scam from the start. You,
I mean, you know, he, he wanted the money and he knew, you know, what, he,
you know, back then we had territories before Vince kind of, you know,
took it nationwide. You know, Texas had a territory,
California had a couple territories, Oregon, you know, and guys just went 2000.
Bucks in 86. A lot of it's a lot money of money.
It's a lot of money for a kid in college, on, you know, on a scholarship.
I didn't have. I, I sold everything I owned, you.
Know, so you're. How do you go from there? So.
Uh, you know, I, I, I lived in my car for a little bit, uh, you know,
bounced in bars, collected a little money here and there.
I just did whatever I could just to, you know, keep eating and,
and keep training and, and, and did what I did, what I could. And I knew,
so Theon Erics ran Dallas. That was their, that was their,
their hub world, world class championship wrestling.
And I knew that they were in the office on Wednesday.
Like they would come in there and book the cards and the guys would come in,
get their paychecks and on Wednesday. So every Wednesday for about eight months,
I would go down there and I'd sit in the lobby
and guys would come right. Walk right by me. Not even,
not even acknowledge my presence every Wednesday,
every Wednesday for eight months, I went and just sat there.
And eight months, did you ask to speak to any well, yeah. So there was,
there was a referee back there. His name was Bronco Lu,
who was the only one that would speak to me. Right. And they, he kinda like, uh,
you here again? Huh? Kid. I was like, uh, yes, sir. Mr. Lubi. I was, you know,
hoping me, I'd get a chance to talk to somebody today. All right.
Well just good luck, you know, and then I would sit there and, you know,
I'd walk by and try, like, you know, as they, somebody would come through,
you know, I'd kind of start to stand. They stop. Just, just blew me,
blew right by me. A like I was, I was right at the end of my,
I like, this is not, I'm not getting anywhere here. And, uh,
Fritz Von Eric, you know, the, the, the patriarch of the family, right.
The guy that owned the company came in and he,
and he walked in and he stopped. And he looked at me
like, and I started to, you know, once again, I started to get up, you know,
and introduce myself.
And he turned around and he went into Bronco's office and he had a deep gravel
voice and I could hear him. And he was like, he's like,
who's that kid out there? And, uh, he said, ah,
he's been coming here for months. He's just trying to get booked. And I heard,
heard Fritz go book him, book him Friday night. I wanna see what he can do.
He looks just like David, one of his sons that he had lost. I looked,
I looked a lot like David, and that's how, that's how I got my first bra.
Wow. Cause I was in the right, you know,
I was in the right place at the right time. So had you ever practiced? No,
I was practicing. I mean, yeah. I mean, I was, but I'd never had a,
I'd never had like a real match. Right. I mean, I'm just, you know,
every little outlaw independent kind of deal that I could get I was doing,
but I hadn't worked with guys or, you know,
when you say like outlaw independent, like, so you were doing some matches.
I was doing some matches, but not, not professional.
Like not televised, not for, for a real company. Right. I see.
It's just like some, like, okay, I'm a wrestling promoter.
I'm gonna go to the Knights of Columbus hall and see if I can put 20 people pull
in here, you know, that's the kind of you were doing.
And then you have to go for no money and then, you know, you'd set up the ring,
whatever you had to do. But the, the wrestling,
the time in the ring was what was so valuable at that point is getting,
getting those reps and getting that stuff. So, and then,
so they booked me and, uh, I don't know if you've heard of bruiser Brody.
Yes. Yes. Tough guy, uh, in anybody's standards back then,
especially is my first match. Right. So
<laugh> now I, I, I'm a pretty respectful guy and, and, and, and,
and I'm sure in any industry, you know, know, even when you, you know,
a new comic, you pay respect to the older guy. I mean,
it's just the way it should be. And, and the way it really was back then,
especially, you know, in our business, you know, you just, you didn't say much,
you spoke when spoken to kind of deal. And, uh,
so I I'm bruiser Brody, bruiser. Brody's my first professional match. Right.
Wow. I don't know. I'm 20, 21 maybe. And, uh,
I'm, you know, I'm in the ring and I'm looking at him, I'm like,
I'm bigger than he is. This is that's going on in my head. Right.
I'm so nervous. Like you couldn't have drove a nail up my with a sledge hammer.
I'm so nervous to start with, but I'm looking like that, that,
that stupid voice in the back of my head, like, you're bigger than he is,
you know, cuz Bruce Brody was bigger than life, man.
He had all that hair and he was just, he was just a man. He was an animal.
Right. So be rings. And I,
boom, I tie up with him collar an elbow and you know,
I jam him up into a corner, you know, he,
Hey kid lightening up a little bit kid, you know, relax. And I'm just like,
I mean, my body's like angle iron. Right. I'm so just whoa. And anyway,
so I go to shove him and my hands know we're kind of hand fighting a little bit
and my hand slips off. And I kind of, you know, I kind of Palm him in the,
in the, in the face temperature in the room,
changed a little bit at that moment. <laugh> we?
So we tie up again and I'm,
I'm about to shoot him across the ring and I shoot him across the,
and I'm yelling like I'm gonna hit him with a clothes line.
So as I tell a clothes line, right. And he comes off the ropes, like,
like a bullet, like a six foot five, 300 pound bullet.
And he kicks me square in my jaw. <laugh>
my, my eyes roll back in my,
and next thing I know he's grabbing me. He's like, let's go for a walk. Right.
So he throws me outta the ring and uh, throws me down on this table.
And, and the, this place called the auditorium in Dallas.
They've torn it down now. But they had the folding chairs that had,
they were metal, but then they had the wood SL.
He takes this chair as hard as he, you know, and not the,
we're not talking about the metal folding chairs,
which hurt enough in their own. Right. When you get hit enough times with them,
he swings as hard as he can. This chair just explodes,
wood SLS fly all over the place. I'm thinking I've,
I've never been hit so hard. Mine I've been hit, you know,
but I'd never been hit that hard by anything. At that point,
he throws me back in the ring, ties me all up in the ropes, right. I'm greener.
Don't know what the hell I'm doing.
And he just starts hitting the other ropes and coming and just kicking me as
hard as he can in the head. Oh my God.
And I deserved it. You know? I mean,
he was giving me a lesson that I needed to learn anyway,
a couple minutes later, boom. He pins me and you know, that was it. We go back,
you know, we go back to the dressing room and I'm like, holy.
I just got the kicked out of me. And uh, I went over to him.
I was like, Mr. Brody, thank you. You know, he said, all right, kid, just,
you know, relax next time will you? And I was like, yes, sir. I, I,
I just appreciate, you know, being in the ring with you and, you know,
went back off of my corner, kind of gather where I was and you know,
and I could over him tell, and you know, the promoter he's like, you ought,
you ought to book this kid some more.
They were trying to find someplace else to send me. He said that kid,
that kid's gonna be something. And uh, but you know,
at the time I was too green, I didn't know what the I was doing.
So I had to go somewhere else. But that was my first, my first, uh,
introduction into, into wrestling and I, I got thumped pretty good.
Catch new episodes. The Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J E videos on Spotify, including clips,
easily seamlessly switch between and audio experience
on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on, on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.